defining who someone is what if
someone's not sure what they really you
know I remember like you'd make these
boards where you'd cut out from
magazines things that you like and
things that are similar to you is it
almost something like that where you you
know I think we know more of who we are
when we r 7 than we do when we're 27 and
and it's you know we we live in a world
of facebook and twitter and an Instagram
where we're constantly bombarded with
other people's experiences and other
people's view of the world and and I
think we need to be as artists be much
more protective of what we what we allow
in because of the because of envy envy
and the desire to live other people's
lives and that competitive sense that
maybe they're doing more than I am or
not enough or I'm somehow not living the
life I should live makes it dilute
syou're sense of yourself and it also no
mind you you need to go say oh wow
Tahiti I'd love to go to Tahiti I'll put
that on my bucket list but I believe in
a lot of practices of whist making and
one of the lists that I always make
there's a list of a hundred of things to
do be in half and in that list of a
hundred and it can be simple things like
I want to have a star I want to have
coffee at the end of the Santa Monica
Pier on a sunset with my boyfriend right
but that list you'll begin to see that
what you think is happiness what you
want to bring into your life is really
unique and it's not like anybody else's
and conglomerate and and when things
those things start manifesting because I
also believe that when you write it down
it comes you see more of yourself in
your life and
so as a writer as an art especially
since so much of us so many of us are
introverts we live in our heads and when
you start making declarations to the
universe this is what I want to do beat
and have in my life you naturally go
look for those things to do be in half
because you get excited by them but the
universe also starts delivering them
which creates more authenticity in
yourself because you become more
yourself because you're getting more of
what you want to do be in half so this
this collection of experiences
reinforces that voice and your attention
to yourself and your desire to be
yourself will also collect more energy
into your authenticity so tell me about
this list a little more so it's it's I'm
sorry hundred things hundred things I
challenge all of you yeah to make a list
okay have a hundred because it's when
you 100 is a lot it is yeah and it's a
hundred things to do be in half and they
can be grand and small so it can be I i
want a cartier tank watch right that's
to have I want to ride an elephant in
India that's due to be I want to be a
big sister to somebody I want to be the
person who everyone turns to at a
Halloween party right so we it's it's
imagining all the things that would
really make you happy and what's
interesting about this exercise is you
realize how little we think about what
really makes us happy on the most micro
levels so you think about okay I want to
have a wreath you when you start reading
it changes it changes your perspective
of how you interact with the world when
you have this hundred list because now
when you read the LA magazine's top 10
strong lists well there's ten
restaurants I got to put that on my list
I want to eat the octopus at ill cugini
I want to taste the sushi at you know
fancy sushi place so you this collection
and begins to you begin to see your
inner world in an external place and
that helps you see yourself do we show
this list to others or is this a
personal list that we just keep to
ourselves um it's it's best to keep it
personal I'm a big believer in not
inviting opinions opinions are wonderful
and there you have to deal with them
when you go pitch your story and you go
out into the marketplace but you should
you should wait until your bubble of
unis of your authenticity is so strong
that other people's opinions bounce off
your bubble and you can hang on to this
world and allow people to beat to see
you because it's transparent and you can
see the world outside but nothing
touches you and if you can live in this
world where you are fully yourself
creating all kinds of fantastic things
from the land that gives you joy and
people can criticize you and tell you
you suck tell you you'll never succeed
and you float around like I have no idea
what you're talking about you won
you